yeah because he's openly talking about
inner Romania I could pay this guy off
and this guy off yeah and it's weird
like do you really want to publicize
that so maybe all the real criminals are
like dude you're acting up our whole
[__] okay so they're paying someone to
go arrest them
[Laughter]
[Music]
so the Tate Brothers have been released
to house arrest oh wow didn't they keep
pushing it like another month another
month yeah
I didn't know they had both brothers
they do yeah so um top G is out and his
brother Tristan they have been moved
from custody to house arrest with
immediate effect from a Romanian judge
and um what's going on people weren't
sure that this was going to happen but
um this just happened like right now
we're actually it's not because of his
health is it what's that does Health
have anything they didn't say anything
about that yeah I got a new haircut
they're just saying that um it's
unnecessarily harsh to keep them in
custody
um win options like house arrest are
still available so why are you guys like
doing extra things to them which you
would normally not do because whatever
they're getting charged with no one
knows if it's like real or not right or
if they're guilty of it well yeah so um
you know alleged victims are claiming to
have been forced to earn a certain
amount of money
um on social media platforms under
threat of physical violence and the idea
is like hey you're forced to do only
Vans or you're forced to like some of
the cam girls they manage basically yeah
and
um core papers describe debts being used
as a form of psychological coercion
um and six women so far have been
identified by prosecutors as victims no
charges have yet been brought against
the brothers so they were held for that
long without charges filed I think
they're gonna score you think they're
gonna want I think they're gonna Escape
you think they'll just like flee
because once not I mean once you get to
house arrest right it makes it so much
easier and if they get out of Romania
then like what's next but how do they
hold somebody for that long without
charges like that's kind of what's
troubling about this well Romania is
crazy corrupt like wildly corrupt like
like just to get just to get like proper
services at a hospital you have to
grease those health workers it's it's
like notoriously known for that there's
been a whole documentary on it on like
like healthcare professionals everybody
going in and just being like poor people
can't get good service like the rich
people just come in or middle class and
just be like yo here's some [__]
whiskey and here's some gifts and here's
some things take care of me first so
everyone who's got money they get yeah
that's crazy because he moved he moved
there to not get in trouble for his [__]
well I think that's why he liked it
because he was like in Greece people
over here it's corrupt I don't have
access to the corruption yeah uh because
like only pop petitions get to get out
of like tickets or whatever over there
everyone has access to the corruption
yeah so what's in it for them then like
to hold the tape Brothers who's who's
shaking them now I think uh that's the
conspiracy thing is that they think
someone else is like pulling those
strings yeah I think it's it's the world
like
they're they're attracting too much
attention so like no organized crime
likes that kind of attention right and
then he also spoke out I think
about Romania being corrupt and easy so
I'm like come on dude do you really want
to oust yourself like that and then that
makes the country look bad and now
that's might have to crack down on them
yeah because he's openly talking about
you know Romania I could pay this guy
off and this guy off yeah and it's weird
like do you really want to publicize
that so maybe all the real criminals are
like dude you're [__] up our whole
[__] okay so they're paying someone to
go arrest them
doesn't that further just expose the
corruption more especially holding them
this long like it's weird I think if
well I think well number one Romania is
a part of the EU right so the
consequences if you don't have your [__]
together you can be kicked out of the EU
possibly right so yeah there's probably
consequences for
being so openly like we're a corrupt
country right yeah so they're basically
forced to stay inside their domicile
until they get expressed permission from
the Judiciary to leave
um I don't know that that hurts them at
all other than like maybe they can start
making stuff again they can make content
yeah that's what I wonder what's their
first video gonna be what's the first
video on Hustler University it doesn't
entertain have like lung cancer or some
[__] he does oh [__] something like that
but it's all speculation nobody actually
knows per se yeah I haven't seen it I I
want the title to be they can't hold me
down do we have any facts about them at
all or is this just all like what do you
mean like the like just anything that
involves them I think so with this guy
it's like Alex Jones right you don't
know which which one is character and
which one's real yeah yeah
um he's a former kickboxer well that's
true he he did kickboxing he did all
those stuff
um he did run a brothel like only fans
like he openly talks about it like it
was an actual brothel bro well it was
only fans brothel so he wasn't getting
girls like so it was it was basically he
got all this ex-girl or girlfriends at
the time together and then they were
just like yo check it out like
you guys do only fans or cam girl stuff
and then we'll like set up the business
so it was like a house and then you know
he had the girls work that and then they
would basically take a cut from that so
it's all like consent and everything
yeah that's what he said and then I know
but then he did have a falling he had a
falling out with one of them too oh so
they're just like trying to plan a like
a revenge and then there's Clips I guess
I don't know if those are even the same
girls of him admitting certain things
and saying like
like basically like it it sounds like um
you know Financial abuse uh emotional
abuse and just certain things of like
how how a pimp basically acts around his
like hookers and stuff right so but how
much was just cool guy talk yeah that's
what I'm saying is I don't know how much
is like hey look at me I'm so cool and
then how much of that was like yeah I
don't know no one it's hard to say right
because like I say I hate my wife all
the time on the show but I
yeah you know I I kind of hate my wife
but I don't like hate my wife but you
don't have a Bugatti though if you have
a Bugatti then it's like people all
those things they believe it yeah so
yeah it's just it's just such a weird
kind of dynamic too because like
like I can't tell if abuse is going down
or not because one of the victims that
accused them there's footage of her
picking up like ubereats and [__] going
back into the house and then like just
hanging out with her friends yeah and
then some might argue well like that
that Stockholm syndrome right like so
what she went up to the car picked up
Uber Eats came back whatever
so I might look at that and be like well
if that was your chance to run you
didn't run exactly you know it's just
that's like Nikki picking up ubereats
with like my shoe print on the back of
her neck
and
you know who did it on their own that's
different if they're afraid of the
consequences if they run yeah that's a
different thing or like where would they
go what if they're runaways what if
they're from different countries right
like they they don't have their passport
or something but the funny thing is he
did admit that like he told the story
about how uh
the uh you know the cam girl chatting
that it's not even them and he just like
cons people into giving all this money
actually Madison dude remember that oh
yeah yeah what do you mean dude medicine
right so this was like um for social
lights and all this stuff to yeah cheat
on your wife but like with hotties and
[__] I remember that yeah like get out
of the [__] wrinkly ass territory
you're in topographical maps and [__]
come on into Ashley Madison and so then
it's just all like [__] dudes sitting
there like almost like a bot Farm but
just dudes be like wow oh yeah like I'm
really horny for you and like you're a
hot old dude I know the database got
compromised I didn't know they was all
so yeah it got a compromised and they
they part of the disclosure of the
discovery of the trial was that actually
imagine having to admit that they were
like heavily heavily heavily male users
so it's like males talking to males all
day long
incredibly good stuff but then it's
still going isn't it yeah sure Ashley
Madison even after that they continued
what's the purpose of Ashley Madison
2x2.com still out there isn't it
I think it was like for like people that
are trying to cheat like swingers it's
extramarital Affairs yeah that's what it
is on both sides guys and girls supposed
to be get out from under the weather
dude
you know what I mean get some like new
ass but yeah they got exposed for their
their database of users went out and
went public so all the dudes that were
cheating on their wives their names were
on that list oh my gosh it was like 70
000. why do you have account there huh
yeah I think I clicked on accident I was
curious and then I signed up search and
I put my address
they asked me who might have made my
papers every month those excuses must
have been gold I wish the excuses was on
a list too because that'd be so funny
every single one of those guys should
have a statue of themselves the the
number one thing for a business like
that to do is to make you an excuse
already like they just give you an alibi
when you sign up just email it to you
yeah so they make this whole elaborate
thing I thought Ashley Madison was this
poor woman from Brazil
you better believe I thought she was
hungry
that would be cool if they disguised it
as some like Evangelical donation thing
where you're like paying tithe but
okay Joel Osteen's Church dude yeah they
were just paying Mosaic or something I
kind of want to see what's on Hustler's
University dude what's that what does
that Andrew Tates think that's his
digital course no dude yeah if you join
it you'll just be too successful you'll
be unrelatable well that's that's what I
want I kind of want to see like I
watched a guy that um broke it down
what'd he say he said that well
basically he was looking at it more from
uh uh digital education point of view
and what's in the church what's he
teaching yeah that's what I mean so the
world that he paints is basically he's
out of this Matrix The Matrix is like
this fake you know wolf world it's to
keep you down whatever it's the rat race
right
but then for him he does what he wants
he's like goes all over the world
because he's out of the Matrix and he's
teaching people basically it's like a
mixture of like motivational [__]
core [__] with uh like be a hustler like
me
um yeah and then how he basically
created like his whole cam girl like
Farm [__] and whatever yeah so he's like
don't wear suits wear like that Walsh
the holy wool sweaters that they had
like outside the Matrix find a stable of
girls that will be down to do only fans
content for you he pouring white
porridge yeah there's a lot yeah don't
eat steaks eat white pork karate from a
video exactly right yeah yeah eat the
cream of wheat yeah exactly
off the lights and hide if there's
noises outside because you're outside
the Matrix now yeah cool it's it's
[__] brilliant it's brilliant you can
see you can see like someone like people
breaking down like the court like course
and what they've like been through yeah
yeah testimonies with like guys that
broke out of the Matrix as well yeah pop
G baby the guy who on Tuesday night he
went to bed and he's like I love you to
my wife and [__] and then he watches
this thing and the next day he's like
hey [__] I'm home you're ugly all right
I'm gonna go wait for my steak you can
make me a steak and I'm gonna wait for
my [__] too cool two coffees the two
coffees one's my favorite dude what did
they say about two coffees he just says
in the morning I want my lady to give me
two copies one because that's the one
I'm gonna drink and one just in case
that's it no because just because it's
because I said so just because I have to
defend you in the night if we get
attacked so you better just make me two
coffees [__]
[__] Sal wait what's Sal
like you're a cow like eat grass yeah I
thought it was abbreviation for
something yeah s-o-w yeah yeah free my
boy dude hey Free Them Boys Freedom boys
foreign
[Music]